thank you for attending my talk i will
present techniques related to color
coding
so i will give a brief high-level
overview overview of three color coding
related techniques divide and color
narrow sieves and representative sets
there are many problems with the best
known algorithms rely on these
techniques
and for example directed kpf we will see
here undirected k perform which you've
already heard
the golf motif problem which i think you
will hear later today
and it is interesting to ask
how much we can improve these algorithms
if we can improve them and i've been
studying mixed tests of this technique
so close to the end of the talk i will
present one result i obtained that
relies on a mixture of dividing color
and representative sets
now for historical reasons i will say a
few words about color coding it led to
the discovery of the first single
exponential time algorithms for many sub
cases of subgraph isomorphism so let's
assume you solve such a sub case
now the problem when we solve such a sub
case of subgraph isomorphism is to avoid
repeating nodes we cannot store the node
set of every partial solution because
there are too many options therefore in
color coding
we use a set of k color and each nodes
get a color the choice is random now
when we look at some specific solution
to our problem then with high
probability
it will be colorful now when it is
colorful it is easy to find it because
we can just use dynamic programming the
point is that now we can store color
sets
and there are only two to the power of k
options and not node sets we'll now see
this in an example so we our example
will be directed kpf for all of the
techniques
and not in that k path you have a
directed graph g and we ask if there is
a directed simple path on k notes so
he'll assume this is part of our graph
and that k6
now each node each node gets a color
here for simplicity let's assume that we
use exactly k colors
now we want to get a colorful solution
so when we look at some solution
assuming that the solution exists this
is the probability that it will be
colorful
now it's important to see here that this
probability is high
because we just want the solution to be
colorful it doesn't matter if the first
node gets the color blue or green or red
it's only important that it doesn't get
a color that a different node here in
the solution
also has
okay so this is why we have this
probability not 1 over k to the power of
k
now a simple calculation shows you that
if you perform this number of coloring
iteration then you will examine at least
one iteration where the solution is
colorful
okay and then in this iteration we would
like to find it
so let's look at such an integration
and when the solution is colorful now to
find it we can just use dynamic
programming in a straightforward manner
we have entries of this form
in such an entry we ask if there is a
path on p notes that ends at node v and
uses the color set s
now and what's important to see here is
that we store color sets and not note
sets this is why in the running time you
have here two to the power of k
okay because we only store in a color
sets and it is okay that we store color
sets and not color multi sets because we
know that the solution is colorful and
of course we can ensure that we do not
repeat notes that we get a simple path
because if a color is not repeated then
a node is not repeated
and i also want to mention in the
context of color coding then it can be
the randomized and it can also hand
elevated the problems just instead of
yes or no you store your weights
okay so now let's
move on and in the in the past decade
three techniques improved upon color
coding first dividing color allows to
develop deterministic algorithms for
weighted problems that are better than
those based on color coding
recently a compute powerful computation
and representative sets allows
developing faster such algorithms the
fastest algorithms however are based on
narrow sieves
but they are randomized and are not well
suited to handle weights
so let's start with dividing color this
can be viewed as a recursive application
of color coding with only two colors so
let's see what exactly it means so here
in each step we have a set a of n
elements and we see a certain subset a
star of k elements in a k a star is our
solution now we color each element in a
in one of two colors say
yellow and red and now we have two new
sub problems we need to find a certain
subset of a star in the set of yellow
elements and the remaining elements of a
star in the set of red elements
let's see this in an example
so our example is directed k-path and
now assume that we don't only ask if
there is a directed k path but for every
pair of nodes v and u we want to find
the solution that starts in at v and
ends it u
okay so now we use the method and we
color each node in red or blue we will
soon see exactly how we colour
the nodes but our goal is that now now
assume that we examine an option where
the first half of the solution of the
kpop is red and the second half is blue
here we will soon see how we will how we
get such a coloring
but assume we are in this situation
and now we have to
simpler subproblems we need to find
paths on k over two notes in the
subgraph induced by the red nodes and a
pf
paths on k over two nodes in the sub
graph induced by the blue nodes and you
can see that if we know how to solve if
we have solutions to these sub problems
then we can find
k paths for example here we can combine
these two solutions because there is an
edge from w to r and of course there
might be other solutions that we need to
return if there is a solution that
starts in a node other than v
and to solve its
sub problem we can use additional
recursive calls
okay so now let's see how we get the
coloring that we want so we need this
definition we say that the family of
functions
from 1 to n to 0 1
is nk universal set if for every subset
of indices
of size k
and the corresponding function f prime
there is a function in f that on i
agrees with f prime okay so this is
exactly what we need because
we know that we will examine we give to
each node an index and we know that we
will examine the function here
well
the notes in the third half of the
solution will get zero so we will give
them the color red and those in the
second half of the solution will get one
so we will give them the color blue okay
so there is a
function that will examine and will give
us the desired coloring
and it is known that a small such family
can be computed efficiently in time of
star to the power of k almost to the
power of k and this is the time we need
for one step okay next we will need to
solve the sub problems that we get and
so on so overall it can be shown that
the time that we need is 4 to the power
of k
okay
now let's move to the narrow sieves
technique
but before this i want to say a few
words about multi-linear detection the
technique from which it evolved because
then it is easier to see the connection
between color coding to multilinear
detection to neural sieves so in
multilinear detection we associate a
monomial with its potential solution so
instead of color sets we have monomials
and we need to ensure that a potential
solution is correct if and only if it is
associated with a multi-linear monomial
okay so instead of ensuring that the
color is not repeated we ensure that a
variable is not repeated in the monomial
okay then
essentially we look at the sum of these
monomials and we reduce
the problem to a different one where we
check if a polynomial a certain
polynomial has a multi-linear monomial
of the greater most t and then there's a
known algorithm that solves it okay it
was given with the technique
okay so now let's see now sieves so
again we associate monomials with
potential solutions but now
we need to ensure that the correct
solution is associated with a unique
monomial
and that an incorrect solution
is associated with an even an incorrect
a monomial this associated with an
incorrect solution is associated with an
even number of such solutions in other
words the set of incorrect solutions can
be partitioned into pairs that have the
same monomial
okay to make this work we need to use a
color set
okay and we need to ensure that our
potential solutions what we will call
potential solutions will be colorful now
some potential solutions are incorrect
and they will also be colorful
but we will be able to handle them by
using
this property
okay
and how do we ensure that we only look
at the colorful potent the potential
solutions are colorful so here we use
enclose and extra closure and we will
soon see this in an example
and
how do we handle the incorrect solution
so just look at the editor sum
and having a field of characteristic two
they just vanish because of this
property so we end up with a problem of
testing whether a certain polynomial is
zero or not and this can be done
efficiently using known tools and here i
mean that we get a randomized algorithm
okay so let's see an example so we use a
set of k colors and we have a variable
for every node and color and a variable
for every edge and when we look at a
solution for example then the monomial
associated with this we take the
variables of the edges okay directed
edges and for each colored node we get
als we have also a variable for so for
example if p were green
q or blue and you are green we will have
this monomial
and of course if a
node is repeated then each of its
occurrences can get a different color
this is exact actually what we would
like we would like to look at the
colorful potential solutions
okay so now we need this definition so
let w x be the set of color works on k
notes avoiding colors from x by works i
mean that notes can be repeated
and w colorful be the set of colorful
works on k notes so w colorful is the
set of the potential solutions
now let's look at the sum of the
monomials corresponding to these
potential solutions now we would like to
evaluate this polynomial but we do not
want to store all of the color sets to
ensure that we really look at colorful
potential solutions we do not want to
store all of the color sets when we use
for example dynamic programming
so here we can use including exclusion
and then you can see that in the inner
sum we can just look at wx
ensure that we avoid using colors from x
so we can have polynomial space
okay and here is 2 to the power of k
because we are looking at every subset
of
c that contains k colors okay so this is
the time
now let's take a closer look is this a
polynomial so if we associated monomials
with potential solutions as we intended
then
you look that you see that
the monomials of the incorrect solutions
they vanish because of this probability
they are partitioned into pairs having
the same monomials can we use the field
of characteristic too so this vanish
says
and we end up with a problem testing
whether a polynomial is a zero or not
okay so now let's just see a short
explanation why we associated monomials
with potential solutions like we
intended to
so
when you look at a monomial associated
with the correct solution then you can
construct the solution from looking at
the monomial we know exactly
which edges to use okay here we use the
variables of the edges and we know
exactly what is the color of each node
in the solution
but when we look you look at a
solutions
okay for example here we look at the
incorrect solution then there is some
node that is repeated look at its first
and second occurrence and just drop the
colors
and you get a different solution because
it is colorful
okay so we got a different solution but
the monomer stays the same we still have
here in this example one extra green and
one xp orange
okay
so now let's move to representative sets
so this is the definition of
reproductive set we have a universe e of
n elements and
let us be a family of subsets of size p
of e now we say that the subfamily s hat
of scale presents s if the following
condition is satisfied
for every pair pair of disjoint sets x
in s
and y whose size is at most k minus p
there is a set in s hat that is also
disjoint from y
so what does it means it means that if
there is a partial solution in the s
that can be extended to a solution by
adding some set y
then there is also a partial solution in
s hat that can be extended to a solution
but in the same set
y so in a sense we keep enough partial
solutions in s hat so we can find the
solution in the end
and we might also remove a lot of
solutions maybe because we are looking
here at a subset of s
okay so how do we usually use this
definition so suppose that we have a
parameterized algorithm that is based on
dynamic programming now at each stage
this algorithm computes the family s of
partial solutions so what will we do we
just compute a family that represents
that and we replaced every reference to
us by reference to the representative
family and by the definition of a
representative family the algorithm
stays correct and it might also be
significantly faster because we are
using now a subfamily that might be
significantly smaller so the question is
can we compute small representative
families efficiently so recently
a powerful computation that answered
this question was presented
okay and i will not give any details
about this computation but there is one
thing that i want to say so we will see
the connection between color coding to
divide in color and then to
representative sets because in this
computation
there is a certain data structure that
is constructed and when it is
initialized it is initialized by the
computation that generalizes the
computations of an nk universal set we
assign the context of dividing color
okay so you can see that there are ideas
from color coding and dividing color
that are used here
so now we just use this as a black box
and we have an algorithm to solve a
directed kpf that is based on standard
dynamic programming it means for example
that we we can compute families of this
form svp and the node sets of directed
paths and p nodes that end ended v
however this
families can be very large
so what we really store are families
that represent them now by using the
computation that i didn't show you the
details it can be shown that this is now
what you actually store the size of the
families that you store and overall it
can be shown that you get this running
time
okay
so i've been studying mixed tests of
this technique and here i will only show
you one mixture that relies on a
combination of
um
representative sets and dividing color
in the context of directed k-path okay
so you can see that we get an
improvement by using
such a mixture
and
also there can be other there are other
mixtures of these techniques can that
can lead to improvements for other
problems and i want to mention that
this results builds on a also builds on
a trade of results that was obtained by
these authors and also in a work i have
with sadashichni
so i will only give you the intuition
that underlies this mixtale so let's
assume that we have someone obtained a
coloring of the nodes
such that if there is a solution there
is a solution that looks like this
only and every ice node is blue okay
here in this example i is four so we
have one two three notes that are red
then one blue one two three red one blue
and so on
next for simplicity
let's uh
the illustration will show a solution
like this okay we don't see here the
notes and the edges but you can imagine
they are there
okay so if we want to use standard
dynamic programming and representative
sets as before
then you can see that the partial
solution will look like this this is the
part of the path we already found and
what is what remains to be found okay so
in the illustration this is a partial
solution
okay so now assume that also we somehow
obtain the partition of the blue part
into dark blue and light blue okay so
that if there is a solution there is a
solution where the dark blue appears in
the beginning of the solution and the
light blue part appears in the end of
the solution okay at the end we will
discuss how to obtain actually this red
blue light blue and dark blue parts okay
so assume that we are in this situation
now how does it help us so the obvious
way is that when we are in the first
half of the computation
then we do not need to ensure this
jointness from the light blue part okay
we simply at this point we only use the
red nodes and dark blue nodes so of
course we do not use any light blue node
and this makes computations of
representative sets faster
now when we are at the second half of
the computation now we are only adding
red nodes and light blue nodes so we do
not need to ensure that we do not repeat
a dark blue notes that we already used
we are only adding light blue notes so
we can actually forget about all of the
dark blue notes that are in our
particular solutions
so again this makes computations of
representative sets faster however this
is not good enough because the time that
we serve in the computations of
representative sets doesn't justify the
time we need to obtain the
dark blue part and light blue part
so let's take a closer look at the worst
time to compute representative sets it's
when we have a family of partial
solutions that contain slightly more
than half of the solution can we when we
are in this situation
however when we look at each part
separately
we we see that
the situation actually remains bad with
respect to the red part it contains
slightly more than half of the red part
but it is actually good with respect to
the dark blue and light blue part it
already contains all of the notes in the
dark blue part so we can even forget
about them
and it contains significantly less than
the half of the notes of the light blue
part okay so we are good with respect to
the dark blue and light blue part
so
we give a more general definition of
representative sets and the necessary
computation
that captures and that exploits this
imbalance
now if we have the blue part then
obtaining the dark blue part and light
blue part it's not a problem because we
just used one step of dividing color
just one standard step of these
techniques and we have the dark blue and
light blue part now obtaining the blue
part is more problematic because we
cannot really obtain a blue part that is
as nice as i showed you in the
illustrations okay what we really do is
we just
obtain a blue part that contains the
desired number of nodes
regardless of their location in the
solution so it means that if we
look at the solution like this so the
blue part can be congested in different
places locations along the solution
and then
we cannot use the idea that is related
to the imbalance so what we do is we use
a porterdo that implicitly cuts the
solution into small directed paths and
reorders there's it so we get a solution
that is relatively nice
but overall it allows us to use ideas
very similar to the ones i told you in
case the solution is organized
okay so we can use the ideas related to
the imbalance
okay so
just to conclude the talk so here i give
you a brief introduction to color coding
related techniques we saw three
techniques
dividing color
representative sets and narrow sieves
and at the end i gave you just one
example
of how we can combine ideas from these
techniques
thank you
well i have one um
if you're combining the color coding and
the multilinear detection
is there is there a possible
algebraic interpretation of what you're
doing like
some of the multilingual stuff is
involved evaluating over exotic range
and so forth is there
any possibility of them
so
i'm not sure but for example already
andreas
algorithm for a kpf it is in a sense
combines divide and color into it
and
yeah so
so
already with no thieves it was shown
that dividing color is relevant
but
yeah
is a very
special assignment
very strict assignment so you can view
it as a registered assignment
which has a very local views of success
and
we view it as a see like
as a black assignment but
that's all i know it's a restricted very
strict assignment
and if you in in if you're using group
algebras
ones are used it would correspond to
using zero one vectors with only one
in some position a dimensional key
what i did was i used general vectors
vectors
that can be arbitrary
but
other than that
and another question is
the multilinear detection
technique
it doesn't give
a natural difference
it doesn't
there's no easy way to get the witness
structure i'm wondering if the color
coding
can be used to speed up
the
discovery of the thing that's promised
to exist
um so so i think that actually it will
be faster to use the multi-linear
detection because then you can remove
the elements from the
graph for example and actually find the
solution in the at the end
so actually
i think that in practice um now saves
multilinear detection
if you're solving problems that do not
have weights
so maybe i have a question
have you thought about actually
getting an approximate counting
algorithm using this uh
combination of these techniques because
uh i think for approximate count the
color recording is still
yes
so one open problem would be
to get a better approximate counting of
k-paths
yeah so so this is a great open question
i didn't think about it
again